[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo especial
informativo aquí en france 24 mi nombre
es liliana valencia si bien el año
pasado estuvo marcado por la pandemia de
kobe 19 sin duda otro de los grandes
temas fue la lucha contra el racismo y
la violencia policial a razón de la
muerte del afroamericano georges floyd a
manos de un policía blanco el 25 de mayo
en minneapolis se levantó un movimiento
sin precedentes en este siglo que puso
la lucha contra la discriminación en la
agenda internacional y que superó las
fronteras de eeuu para extenderse por
europa áfrica y américa latina iniciamos
este especial con un recuento de los
casos de violencia policial contra
ciudadanos afroamericanos que tuvieron
lugar durante 2020 y que dieron un nuevo
impulso al movimiento black light matter
con masivas protestas en todo el país
el 23 de febrero de 2020 el ever y fue
asesinado a tiros por un ex policía
blanco y su hijo mientras flotaba en
georgia peón a taylor murió el 13 de
marzo en louisville kentucky cuando
policías ingresaron a su apartamento y
abrieron fuego
george's floyd falleció el 25 de mayo en
minneapolis cuando un policía blanco se
arrodilló sobre su cuello durante más de
8 minutos el 12 de junio gration brooks
murió al recibir dos tiros en la espalda
en la planta el 23 de agosto en kenosha
wisconsin gay con blake recibió siete
disparos en la espalda y aunque
sobrevivió a las heridas perdió la
movilidad de sus piernas tenía el plus
falleció asfixiado en marzo de 2020 pero
su caso se hizo visible hasta septiembre
cuando el vídeo de su muerte generó una
nueva ola de protestas
estos casos le dieron la vuelta al mundo
despertando la indignación de millones
de personas que se volcaron a las calles
principalmente de eeuu la ola de
manifestaciones inició tras la muerte de
georg floyd en decenas de ciudades
durante varias semanas personas de todas
las etnias se lanzaron a las calles para
pedir el fin de la violencia policial
que afecta sistemáticamente a los
afroamericanos las protestas estuvieron
acompañadas también de disturbios y del
derribo de estatuas y otros símbolos
colonialistas y esclavistas en el país
la presión fue tal que el marcas como
ansia máxima decidieron cambiar sus
logotipos al igual que equipos de fútbol
americano como los redskins de
washington entre muchos otros en todo el
continente e incluso en europa
la mayoría de los asesinatos quedaron
registrados en vídeos que le dieron la
vuelta al mundo a través de los medios
de comunicación y también de las redes
sociales para analizar esta información
saludamos a federico pita asesor de
temas de racismo y afrodescendencia del
instituto nacional contra la
discriminación y el racismo justamente
en argentina quien se conecta con
nosotros desde buenos aires bienvenido
france24 federico y cuéntenos porque se
puede afirmar que el 2020 fue un año
marcado por la lucha contra el racismo a
partir de los casos de violencia
policial que se hicieron visibles en
eeuu principalmente
mira me parece que la clave está en que
el contexto de la pandemia lo que lo que
crujió fue el sistema mundo mismo los
valores sobre lo que está cimentado los
valores sociales o la forma en la que se
rigen las sociedades y me parece que lo
que exaltó la pandemia son esas
inequidades de carácter sistémico como
venía denunciando vos en tu intervención
entonces me parece que en ese caso el
énfasis muy patriarcado y tantos otros
métodos de control y presión social se
vieron exacerbados y magnificados por el
contexto de la pandemia entonces no sé
si es necesariamente noticia el
asesinato de un afroestadounidense a
manos de policías racistas y lo que me
parece que fue la gota que como el vaso
y en definitiva lo que terminó
presentando es que como están dadas las
cosas así no se puede seguir entonces me
parece que esos monumentos que se
derrocaron esas movilizaciones en el
norte global en su global me parece que
lo que marcan es un punto de inflexión
en relación a qué tipo de sistema
o qué tipo de democracias estamos
dispuestos a seguir tolerando con las
abrumadoras mayorías por fuera pues
justamente vamos a hablar ahora de
américa latina porque las protestas que
tuvieron lugar en eeuu y que no tuvieron
precedentes de esta década se replicaron
también en la región por varios casos de
violencia policial quedaron a su vez
reflexiones sobre el racismo sistemático
que se vive en américa latina países
como méxico colombia brasil vivieron
protestas por las muertes de ciudadanos
con características racistas a manos de
la policía veamos
la ola de protestas en contra de la
violencia policial que sacudió a eeuu
durante el 2020 también se sintió en
américa latina donde casos similares a
los de eeuu salieron a la luz en méxico
el joven giovanni lópez murió después de
ser arrestado y presuntamente torturado
por la policía el 4 de mayo de 2020 en
el municipio de ixtlahuacán de los
membrillos en el estado de jalisco tras
su muerte centenares de jóvenes se
lanzaron a las calles bajo la consigna
justicia para giovanni pidiendo reformas
al cuerpo de policía en colombia la
historia se repitió cuando la familia de
anderson arboleda denunció que el joven
afro colombiano murió el 21 de mayo
después de que un policía blanco lo
golpeara en la cabeza en repetidas
oportunidades a pesar de las
movilizaciones presenciales y virtuales
el caso quedó en la impunidad y en
brásil las imágenes de la muerte de job
alberto silveira freitas quien fue
asesinado a golpes el pasado 19 de
noviembre por parte de los vigilantes de
un almacén de carrefour en la ciudad de
porto allegre llevaron a días de
movilizaciones masivas en uno de los
países con más altas cifras de violencia
policial en contra de la población
afrodescendiente
a todos los días alguien muere todos los
días una persona pro muere cada 23
minutos un hombre afro muere asesinado
en las manifestaciones en américa latina
han estado acompañadas de profundas
reflexiones sobre la simbología
colonialista que persiste en la
educación lo mismo ocurre en el espacio
público donde estatuas de personajes
esclavistas han sido derribadas como una
manera de rechazar los conciertos de
supremacismo blanco que está camuflados
en la historiografía tradicional pues
justamente vamos a continuar con nuestro
invitado federico pita para preguntarle
si la situación de violencia policial y
racismo que se vive en eeuu puede
equipararse a la de américa latina' o si
la situación en la región es peor igual
o de pronto mejor y qué cambios se
requieren para transformar esta realidad
bueno evidentemente lo que está siendo
necesario es un cambio de paradigma no
solo me costaría imaginar si es peor o
menor o cuantificar el valor de la vida
en algún lugar del planeta lo que no se
sostiene más es seguir dividiendo el
mundo entre europeos y los europeos y
eso clasificando el valor de las vidas
en el informe lo mostraban en méxico en
brasil en colombia o en argentina o en
cualquiera en cualquier espacio donde se
sigue planteando esta idea este lema de
las vidas negras importan tienen que ver
con el paradigma que sigue sosteniendo
el supremacismo blanco esta idea de que
cuando uno imagina derechos humanos
tiene como horizonte la revolución
francesa que a la hora de la puesta en
práctica en verdad no consideraba
humanos a los habitantes de sus colonias
a sus esclavizados me parece que la
matriz colonial de cómo nos pensamos en
términos sociales en algún aspecto sigue
intacta y afecta de forma directa a las
concepciones de las prácticas sociales o
democráticas y sobre todo si uno piensa
en los avances de la derechas
fascistas en determinadas en
determinadas sociedades y la pregunta y
el desafío está puesto a ver cómo se
construye una propuesta frente a esa
realidad y me parece que estas protestas
otros niveles de conciencia frente a lo
que es el fenómeno del racismo
estructural me parece que son las pistas
de ir construyendo un camino más
democrático pues agradecemos a nuestro
invitado de buenos aires federico pita
por sus intervenciones y apreciaciones y
es que europa las protestas también
llegaron en varias ciudades para pedir
justicia en el caso de ada matador en
quien falleció a manos de la policía en
2016 también de un productor musical que
fue golpeado brutalmente por la policía
en parís en el mes de noviembre el caso
quedó grabado en un vídeo que se hizo
viral y que generó manifestaciones
contra el racismo en varias ciudades del
país galo durante el año decenas de
estatuas de colonialistas y esclavistas
fueron derribadas en diferentes ciudades
europeas como bruselas bélgica y bristol
en reino unido- la ciudadanía pide un
cambio estructural y sistémico en la
educación actual basada en ideas
colonialistas así como reformas a la
policía para evitar excesos en el uso de
la
pues justamente también hablamos
previamente con el historiador ante un
mito así que presidente del consejo para
la eliminación de racismo y la
discriminación en españa a quien le
preguntamos cuál es la importancia de
que esas reflexiones contra el racismo
se hagan también en europa y que se
requiere para generar un cambio
sustancial en cuanto a la problemática
del racismo en el continente
bueno es importante tener en cuenta que
el racismo surgió en europa el racismo
como fenómeno de la contemporaneidad
vinculado a la expansión colonial
europea
por lo tanto europa es la creadora del
racismo y muy particularmente españa en
españa surgió el racismo como una forma
de justificar su victoria sobre otros
pueblos sometimiento a otros pueblos y
su dominio y explotación de otros
pueblos entonces la propia europa es la
que tiene la principal responsabilidad a
la hora de cambiar estos discursos que
han venido difundiendo por el mundo para
asentar su supremacía una supremacía que
en el fondo es política y económica
sobre todo pero que se sustenta en las
ideas racistas de la inferioridad del
resto de pueblos del mundo entonces es
fundamental que europa y sus
instituciones que además tienen una
larga tradición de terribles genocidios
racistas stretton tengan la
responsabilidad tomen la responsabilidad
de acabar con esta lacra ideológica que
es el racismo
ha sido conocido este año pues lo que ha
sido dado en llamar el movimiento
iconoclasta de derribo de esculturas
pues tiene una gran significación es de
gran importancia porque se está
glorificando toda esa gesta europea del
sometimiento de otros pueblos por la
fuerza y por la violencia que es una
violencia doble que es la violencia de
las armas que está apoyada por la
violencia discursiva esa violencia
discursiva viene apoyada por el sistema
educativo por el sistema por lo político
por el sistema de fronteras todos estos
sistemas forman un entramado que
llamamos el racismo estructural y de los
cuales una de sus ramificaciones más
importantes es el racismo institucional
y claro que es bastante evidente el
racismo cuando vemos atropellos por
parte de la policía violencia policial o
incluso asesinatos policiales ahí se
hace muy palpable el racismo pero el
autismo permite a todos los ámbitos de
la sociedad se encuentra inserto en
muchas capas y en muchos niveles y desde
la cotidianidad más absoluta
las barreras para el acceso al empleo
desde los bloqueos institucionales que
existen en europa desde la creación de
una europa sólo blanca solo católica
solo cristiana y solo solo de origen
europeo pues hasta lo que podemos lo que
es en la propia violencia y en europa
también son errores de particularmente
en las fronteras pues son las opiniones
de antoñito así y federico pita
invitados a esta especial informativa
otras 24 a propósito del 2020 un año que
se destacó sin duda por la lucha contra
el racismo el pensamiento colonialista y
la violencia policial ustedes pueden ver
esta información y mucho más en nuestra
página web france24 puntocom nos vemos
más adelante con más información
quédense con nosotros
[Música]